Shure: 我切西瓜去了
Shure: I'm going to cut the watermelon.
Shure的女友:嗯
Shure's GF: Hmm.
Lucia:哈哈你是不是回不去了
Lucia: Haha, are you stuck here?
Shure: 不行
Shure: Nope.
Shure的女友:明天班还上不上了
Shure's GF: Are you going to work tomorrow?
Shure: 我得回我真想学校门口的面了
Shure: I need to go back. I really miss the noodles at the school gate.
Shure: 因为写论文其实在这也能写
Shure: Actually, I can write my thesis here.
Shure: 但是在宿
Shure: But in the dorm...
Shure: 在宿舍可能氛围会更好一些吧
Shure: The atmosphere might be better in the dorm.
Shure: 他们肯定就会拉着我直接打游戏去
Shure: They will definitely drag me to play games.
Shure: 哎呀修硕别写
Shure: "Hey Shure, stop writing."
Shure: 没事那24号一天就够你写的了
Shure: "It's okay, you can finish it in one day on the 24th."
Shure: 妈的我都能想象的到
Shure: Damn, I can imagine it.
Shure: 我说真的吗
Shure: "Seriously?"
Shure: 来吧那就哈哈哈
Shure: "Come on, let's go, haha."
Shure: 主要他们那天你知道在
Shure: Mainly, you know, that day...
Shure: 在下面给我一顿洗脑
Shure: They brainwashed me downstairs.
Shure: 你不在的时候就说
Shure: When you weren't around, they said...
Shure: 你想想你一个本科生
Shure: "Think about it, you're just an undergrad."
Shure: 谁会挂你啊
Shure: "Who's gonna fail you?"
Shure: 对不对 你租这样
Shure: "Right? You rent..."
Shure: 你租服务器
Shure: "You rent servers..."
Shure: 你已经超过90%人
Shure: "You're already ahead of 90% of people."
Shure: 你已经很牛逼了
Shure: "You're already awesome."
Shure: 对然后我就被洗脑
Shure: Yeah, and then I got brainwashed.
Shure: 然后我就本来那天晚上就要把它写完
Shure: I was going to finish it that night.
Shure: 后来想想还可以再等等
Shure: But then I thought, I can wait a bit longer.
Shure: 我才想起来
Shure: I just remembered...
Shure: 我们这没有菜板
Shure: We don't have a cutting board.
Shure: 他能当菜板使吗
Shure: Can this be used as a cutting board?
Shure: 我在这切了
Shure: I'll cut it here.
Shure: 刀来
Shure: Knife, please.
Shure: 西瓜
Shure: Watermelon.
Shure: Masaki的大厨
Shure: Masaki's the chef.
Shure: 裤子都是脏的
Shure: His pants are dirty.
Shure: 没事我会好好爱护她的
Shure: It's okay, I'll take good care of her.
Shure: 我真的记得
Shure: I really remember...
Shure: 我好像有印象把你这条裤子穿过
Shure: I have an impression of wearing these pants before.
Shure: 我而且那种感觉啊
Shure: And that feeling...
Shure: 没有
Shure: Nothing.
Shure: 而且我还感觉给室友看过
Shure: And I think I showed it to my roommate too.
Shure: 我靠
Shure: Oh man.
Shure: 但是可可能可能就是做梦
Shure: But maybe, maybe it was just a dream.
Shure: 就是真的就是这个感觉
Shure: It really felt like that.
Shure: 是一模一样
Shure: It was exactly the same.
Shure: 就是而且就是这条裤子
Shure: And it was these pants.
Shure: 就是这个裙子
Shure: And this skirt.
Shure: 套
Shure: Set.
Shure: 来把刀吧
Shure: Hand me the knife.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 还下吗
Shure: Is it still coming down?
Shure: 哦不下了基本上
Shure: Oh, not really anymore.
Tasha:突然间感觉有点冷
Tasha: Suddenly feels a bit cold.
Shure: 欧玛萨克
Shure: Oh my sock.
Shure: 好
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 你成了雨轩的替身了
Shure: You've become Yuxuan's stand-in now.
Shure: 那我们就可以录一些珍贵数据
Shure: Now we can record some valuable data.
Shure: 那给她也没有用啊
Shure: But it won't help her.
Shure: 她也没有APP开不了
Shure: She doesn't have the app, can't use it.
Jake:呃我我我拿一台有APP的备用手机
Jake: Uh, I'll grab a backup phone that has the app.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Shure: 你让他给你开100
Shure: Ask him to give you 100.
Shure: 开300块钱
Shure: Make it 300 bucks.
Shure: 哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure: 洗一下吗
Shure: Wanna wash up?
Shure: 我把袖子挽上去
Shure: I'll roll up my sleeves.
Shure: 谢谢你妈妈
Shure: Thanks, Mom.
Shure: 我最爱你了
Shure: Love you the most.
Shure: 妈妈
Shure: Mom.
Jake:哼
Jake: Hmph.
Shure: 哦你醒了
Shure: Oh, you're awake.
Shure: 唉本来刚刚准备拿这个眼镜
Shure: Ugh, I was just about to grab these glasses.
Shure: 录点好玩的东西来着
Shure: Record something fun.
Shure: 哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 其实不下了外面已经
Shure: Actually, it's not coming down anymore outside.
Shure: 没事
Shure: No worries.
Shure: 哦shit我还少装一个那个
Shure: Oh shit, I forgot to install that thing.
Shure: 你帮我把那个装上
Shure: Can you help me put it on?
Shure: 来吧
Shure: Come on.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure: 你给他上面塞个纸
Shure: Just put some paper on top for him.
Shure: 把这个拔下去
Shure: Pull this out.
Shure: 对不不不是不是不不不不
Shure: No, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Shure: 你把这个把手哎
Shure: Grab this handle, hey.
Shure: 对然后上面塞个纸
Shure: Yeah, then stuff some paper in there.
Shure: 大家要哙着吃
Shure: Everyone needs to eat it like this.
Shure: 还是切成这样
Shure: Or cut it like this.
Shure: 对嗯然后把粉倒出去然后包着全是
Shure: Yeah, then pour the powder out and wrap it all up.
Shure: 你好聪明哎
Shure: You're so smart.
Shure: 您当 以后家您当
Shure: You should take care of the house from now on.
Shure的女友:我不
Shure's GF: I don't want to.
Shure: 这不有你吗
Shure: But you're here, right?
Lucia:哎哎我手呢 有一点甜
Lucia: Hey, hey, my hand, it's a bit sweet.
Lucia:不会是蛋糕吧
Lucia: Is it cake?
Shure: 手帮少爷干活呢
Shure: Hands are busy working, of course.
Shure: 当然没了
Shure: Obviously not.
Shure: 我要走了雨轩
Shure: I'm leaving, Yuxuan.
Shure:  我 是的
Shure: Yes, I am.
Shure: 吃完西瓜我就走了
Shure: I'll leave after eating the watermelon.
Shure: 我不吃了
Shure: I won't eat it.
Shure: 我想宿舍不是学校门口的面馆
Shure: I think the dorm isn't like the noodle shop at the school gate.
Shure: 不用给我包这么严
Shure: No need to wrap me up so tightly.
Shure: 我回拆也很麻烦的喽
Shure: It'd be a hassle to unwrap anyway.
Shure的女友:你回去你找个剪刀一剪就
Shure's GF: When you get back, just find scissors and cut it.
Shure: 你说我下次再没
Shure: What if next time...
Shure: 没整干净
Shure: I don't clean it properly?
Shure: 打进点塑料
Shure: And it gets some plastic in it?
Shure: 然后再再中毒了
Shure: Then I get poisoned again.
Shure的女友:塑料吃下去不会的
Shure's GF: Eating plastic won't do that.
Shure的女友:人体内下有无数的塑料
Shure's GF: Our bodies are full of plastic already.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 天呐
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure: 再见了雨轩
Shure: Goodbye, Yuxuan.
Shure: 今晚我就要远航
Shure: Tonight, I'm setting sail.
Shure: 我走了
Shure: I'm leaving.
Shure: 还会再见吗呵
Shure: Will we meet again? Heh.
Shure: 再见你要幸福
Shure: Goodbye, be happy.
Shure: 燕子 燕子
Shure: Swallow, Swallow.
Shure: 没有你我怎么活呀燕子
Shure: How will I live without you, Swallow?
Shure: 西瓜怎么切啊哈哈
Shure: How do you cut the watermelon? Haha.
Shure: 来了来了来了
Shure: Here he comes, here he comes, here he comes.
Shure的女友:你为什么不把下面那个切
Shure's GF: Why don't you cut the bottom part?
Shure的女友:切掉
Shure's GF: Cut it off.
Shure: 屁股
Shure: The bottom.
Shure的女友:我来吧我来吧我来吧我来吧
Shure's GF: Let me do it, let me do it, let me do it.
Shure: 怕切着你手
Shure: I'm afraid you'll cut yourself.
Shure的女友:不会你你别
Shure's GF: No, you don't...
Shure的女友:哎呀
Shure's GF: Oops.
Shure的女友:你别动你别动你别动
Shure's GF: Don't move, don't move, don't move.
Shure的女友:你就不该问问我
Shure's GF: You should've asked me.
Shure: 哈您来吧
Shure: Haha, you do it.
Shure: 这碗放盘里吧
Shure: Put this bowl on the plate.
Shure: 哇哇好甜啊
Shure: Wow, wow, it's so sweet.
Shure: 这一个瓜50块钱
Shure: This melon costs 50 yuan.
Shure: 真的吗
Shure: Really?
Shure: 我们家瓜可便宜了真的
Shure: Our melons are really cheap, seriously.
Shure: 我的妈呀
Shure: Oh my god.
Shure: 我天呐
Shure: Oh dear.
Shure: 你居然会切瓜
Shure: You can actually cut melons.
Katrina: 哼哈哈哈
Katrina: Hmph, hahaha.
Katrina: 危险数据真的是
Katrina: Dangerous data, really.
Shure: 小朋友们切勿模仿
Shure: Kids, don't try this at home.
Shure的女友:不是下雨了
Shure's GF: Isn't it raining?
Shure的女友:他那个包上面有块电子屏啊
Shure's GF: There's an electronic screen on his bag.
Shure: 没事
Shure: It's fine.
Shure的女友:防水
Shure's GF: Waterproof.
Shure: 应该吧
Shure: Maybe.
Shure的女友:应该吧
Shure's GF: Maybe.
Katrina: 我衣服还在楼下
Katrina: My clothes are still downstairs.
Shure: 外面现在不下了
Shure: It's not raining outside now.
Shure: 我没有
Shure: I don't have it.
Shure: 我就瞅一眼
Shure: I'm just taking a look.
Shure: 妈呀太厉害了
Shure: Oh my, that's impressive.
Shure: 会叠衣服会切瓜了
Shure: You can fold clothes and cut melons.
Shure: 可以了可以了赶紧娶过来吧
Shure: That's enough, that's enough, hurry and marry her.
Shure: 哈哈不多见了已经
Shure: Haha, it's rare these days.
Shure: 天呐哈哈哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Oh my god, hahahahahaha.
Shure: 叫什么还
Shure: What do you call it?
Shure: 还来气了还
Shure: You're still getting angry?
Shure: 还能伺候起
Shure: Can still serve you.
Shure: 应该把那瓜瓜心拿出来自个吃
Shure: You should take that melon heart out and eat it yourself.
Shure: 好吧
Shure: Alright.
Shure: 滴滴滴
Shure: Beep beep beep.
Shure: 来吃瓜
Shure: Come eat melon.
Shure: 吃瓜
Shure: Eat melon.
Shure: 吃瓜 吃瓜
Shure: Eat melon, eat melon.
Katrina: 你看你要走了
Katrina: Look, you're leaving.
Katrina: 老天都下雨了
Katrina: Even the heavens are crying.
Katrina: 哎小猫咪又来了
Katrina: Ah, the little kitty is back again.
Katrina: 他刚看着我跑了
Katrina: He just looked at me and ran away.
Katrina: 你看它又跑
Katrina: Look, he's running again.
Katrina: 感觉他在观察人类
Katrina: Feels like he's observing humans.
Katrina: 你知道吗
Katrina: You know?
Katrina: 又走了
Katrina: He's gone again.
Shure: 不下了
Shure: It's not raining anymore.
Shure: 现在外面不下了
Shure: It's not raining outside now.
Shure: 家人们
Shure: Guys,
Shure: 不下了哎
Shure: It's not raining anymore, hey.
Shure: 看错了对不起
Shure: Sorry, I was wrong.
Shure: 不是
Shure: No...
Shure: 我第一眼差点顺口叫个宝哈哈
Shure: At first glance, I almost called you 'babe', haha.
Shure: 不下了吧
Shure: It's not raining, right?
Shure: 走吧
Shure: Let's go.
Shure: 你告诉他们一声
Shure: You tell them.
Shure: 我估计放
Shure: I guess put it...
Shure: 放上面吧
Shure: Put it on top.
Shure: 下面没地了
Shure: There's no space below.
Shure: 也也不行也没地
Shure: Also, no space below.
Shure: 真的真的
Shure: Really, really.
Shure: 你放进去
Shure: Put it in.
Shure: 好的
Shure: Okay.
Shure: 哪个 不是
Shure: Which one? No...
Shure: 我电脑都没装
Shure: I didn't even install my computer.
Shure:  我才发现
Shure: I just realized.
Shure: 哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure: 额 死了我电脑没装
Shure: Ugh, my computer's not set up.
Shure: 走
Shure: Let's go.
Shure: 拎包
Shure: Grab the bag.
Shure: 小助理
Shure: Little assistant.
Shure: 好的杨老板
Shure: Okay, Jake.
Shure: 还有半个瓜在楼上
Shure: There's still half a melon upstairs.
Shure: 然后你们想吃的话记得切着吃
Shure: If you want to eat it, remember to cut it up.
Shure: 然后
Shure: And then...
Shure: 是遗嘱是吧
Shure: It's the will, right?
Shure: 对遗嘱了
Shure: Yeah, it's the will.
Shure: 最后教再交代两句
Shure: Lastly, just a couple more things.
Shure: 然后线 归还
Shure: Then, the line, return it.
Tasha:所以你们走
Tasha: So you guys are leaving?
Tasha:你们回去
Tasha: Going back?
Tasha:回去了吗
Tasha: Are you going back?
Shure: 对我们准备回去了直接
Shure: Yeah, we're getting ready to head back.
Jake:就刷一刷
Jake: Just wash it up.
Jake:比如说那个盘子吗
Jake: Like, the dishes, right?
Katrina: 我说这些没有用完的
Katrina: I mean, these things we haven't finished using.
Shure: 我的手机
Shure: My phone.
Katrina: 你带回去吗
Katrina: Are you taking it back?
Shure: 把这个都停掉
Shure: Turn all this off.
Tasha:扔掉好浪费啊
Tasha: Throwing it away is such a waste.
Tasha:带回去我在学校也没法做呀
Tasha: If I take it back, I can't use it at school.
Jake:好说
Jake: No worries.
Jake:卖掉
Jake: Sell it.
Tasha:卖掉
Tasha: Sell it.
Tasha:你卖分我一半就行
Tasha: You sell it, and just give me half.
Jake:为什么 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Why? Hahaha.
Tasha:可是他要两他两包起卖
Tasha: But he wants to sell at least two packs.
Tasha:两包好像才5块钱
Tasha: Two packs are only like 5 yuan.
Katrina: 主要是卖给谁啊
Katrina: The main thing is, who would buy it?
Tasha:玉米淀粉
Tasha: Cornstarch.
Tasha:做汤可能会用到
Tasha: Might be used for making soup.
Tasha:寄给我妈吧
Tasha: Send it to my mom.
Katrina: 哦他这能寄快递
Katrina: Oh, they can deliver it.
Katrina: 能上门取件吗
Katrina: Can they pick it up?
Jake:对这个可以
Jake: Yeah, they can.